um
all right so after that great
introduction this morning to matrix
algebra and a lot of pointers ahead to
michael
you've got a lot on your plate here i
have a lot of them a lot of my plate and
a lot to live up to right so when you
have a good introduction you can only go
downhill
so petros did a nice job sort of uh
providing a background i guess on a lot
of the basic ideas
that have been developed over the years
the last 10 or 15 years
on using randomization for matrix
computations
so i think it's certainly true that
you know if you think about large data
or big data
in any sense of the word i mean two
thousand by a half million or something
a bit smaller a bit larger
um yes as petros and mike said you know
i mean linear algebra matrix
computations are totally bread and
butter right so having to wrestle with
these issues is definitely
true but moreover i mean i think
that this particular example of
randomized algorithms for matrices
is a particularly nice test case of
how to develop algorithmic and
statistical methods for large-scale data
more generally
and there's a range of reasons for that
um so i don't know if alex
is still here but he gave a good example
of that this morning so he was saying
you know we want this more general
embedding result would like to have um
not an embedding but sort of an implicit
embedding or i think he called it a
computational
algorithmic embedding such that we have
something going to rn
and he said but to do the analysis you
know it's hard to encode bits in rn and
so on
so let's go to the hamming cube i think
he had or something and that's what
really gets i think at the heart of
of some of the tensions here because
it's much more natural to think in
computer science about things being
discrete because you can encode you know
solutions to the halting problem or
something in in
real numbers right so how do you how do
you model computation on the real
numbers
and yet you know vector spaces are just
very very nice places matrices
compared to arbitrary metric spaces i
mean you saw that again and again uh
with alex
and matrices are just a very natural way
to think about data you know whether
that data comes from scientific
applications
or or or financial applications i mean
scientific meaning something you know a
lot about the generating processes
relatively
or internet applications where you don't
they're just a nice way to think about
modeling data
and so um the fact that you're in a
vector space buys you a lot you can get
a lot of inferential
consequences as a result of that um and
it buys a lot algorithmically i mean n
cubed is better than two to the n right
um but but really wrestling with the
questions what does it mean to be good
low rank
and so i'll describe some of these
things but good could mean you want to
get the top part of the spectrum and
petros is describing that
it could mean you want to get the top
part of the spectrum and some control on
the bottom part of the spectrum and
depending on the particular structural
result you use
you either can or cannot do that if you
just hit the matrix with a random
projection typically you don't directly
but maybe it's implicit in the analysis
and you don't know you
have that and so i think statisticians
and computer scientists and machine
learners and
downstream scientists who use this stuff
all think about a matrix
just in very different ways and so a lot
of the
frustrations and successes and failures
we've had in bringing some of these
ideas to fruition
may be a good model um you know if
you're serious about thinking about
these sort of large scale issues and
sort of the interface between
computation and statistics
so petros talked about the past a bit of
the present i'll talk about
a bit of the present and i'll look
forward to maybe some future directions
here's the road map so
we're going to be thinking about
let's call it sketching matrices and by
sampling
rows or columns via
some sort of non-trivial important
sampling distribution typically
or via a random projection and you
should think about the random
projections not in a more general way
like
johnson linen straw so that's true but
you should think of that in a lot of
these applications as essentially
rotating you to a random basis where the
relevant non-uniformity structures are
uniformized and petros gave some
examples of that
that you can sample in some smart way
for the matrix products
or you can make that inner samp quote
sampling matrix a sketching matrix
dense essentially a random projection if
you're familiar with those ideas
you know those constructions he was
giving would give you johnson lyndon
stress type results
but it essentially rotates you to a
random basis where the non-uniformity
structure is nice and so in particular
there's no large
rank one components in that randomly
rotated space
and an important theme in a lot of this
stuff is in one way or another you're
feeding through matrix multiplication
which is which is sort of the primitive
you should think about that appears lots
of times in the analysis
and also the idea of decoupling the
randomization from the vector space
structure right johnson's whole just
more
much more generally in metric space
structures and it's oftentimes too
powerful a hammer
to get very fine results on these matrix
computations and even as he was saying
you know
we've made the theory practice gap a lot
less than it has been in the past but
it's still non-trivial and and and to
get finer results you really need to
understand the the uh vector space
structure and in a sense getting
deterministic or structural results and
then applying the randomness much more
carefully and that can be done
explicitly in the algorithm or
implicitly in analysis oftentimes it
gets you much better results so those
are some themes that i'll talk in a
little bit more detail about and then
show you how
going forward some of these things may
manifest themselves in in
theory and in implementations and in
machine learning and data applications
so petra's covered the first four topics
some sort of motivation matrix
multiplication
cx cur projection low rank
approximations and a range of other
things
so i'm going to continue with a few sort
of general ideas
and then i'm going to talk about least
squares
and least squares is a nice sort of very
simple example just over constrained
least squares
no regulations no fat mate i mean just
the simplest thing you can imagine
and um and show you sort of why these
algorithms work and this is going to be
an algorithmic perspective meaning
here's the data and chew on it you know
call your black box and i want an answer
here
and most of the results that petra was
describing that i'll be describing adopt
that perspective basically
and although the randomness is inside
the algorithm you might imagine that
you know the randomness might denoise
the data in some way and so you might
get improved statistical results
so in a lot of cases you do see that you
know you get some regularization
properties
why that's the case is just starting to
i think be understood
and so i'd like to describe a little bit
sort of a statistical perspective on
least squares
where now you say i have a model i'm
doing least squares because the model is
the quote right thing to do and i want
to get such and such results
and this will highlight i think some of
the differences between the two
approaches
and one's not uniformly better than the
other but they offer slightly different
perspectives
and then go back to machine learning
kernels symmetric positive semi-definite
matrices
where you're not as rectangular you know
you have a large matrix in this case
it'll be a
kernel if you know what that is
and this will be in large the lowercase
l you know so not huge but
large enough that the sampling and
projection algorithms will give
non-trivial results but small enough
that we can do full computations to
compare
and uh and see how things behave and
i'll not go into much of the empirical
results but
i'll give you a few examples of what i'm
talking about and then maybe
some theory and practice of implementing
these ideas in much larger scale
settings so i'm going to talk just about
l2 regression and i think i have one
slide summarizing l1 regression
um the same ideas we'll go through there
that's what petrus was talking about we
can we can do least absolute deviations
so the thing gauss would have done had
he been able to do that but he put a
square and
you know did gaussian elimination and so
on and did least squares regression
and so that's the thing that people do
because they can so we we can do least
absolute deviations to regression to
moderate precision you know three digits
four digits five digits of precision
on a terabyte of data um and at a high
level you use the same ideas that petrus
is talking about
there's a theory practice gap and at a
slightly lower level there's a lot of
interesting
practical questions and a lot of
interesting theoretical questions and
what's what's a good way to think about
large data that's not in ram
is the streaming model that people have
you know thought about in the theory of
algorithm is quite the right way to do
it
or is it more appropriate to have some
other type of model and then those won't
give you answers today but those will be
a lot of the things we'll revisit
so randomized algorithms why
so in some cases you just get faster
worst case results
here's your input i want worst case
guarantees i want to be faster
sometimes you get simpler algorithms if
you know the details of numerical code
it's pretty complex you have pivot rule
decisions lots of if statements check
this that
a lot of times you just get simpler
algorithms you know why is that maybe
the randomness fuzzes stuff out a little
bit and so
you're a little bit less sensitive the
details of pivot rule decisions
um maybe a range of other things you
know the randomness might give you
better condition number properties so in
certain cases you might actually even be
able to form the normal equations and so
on
so a lot of times you get simpler
algorithms more interpretable output
so my experience this is something that
machine learners
people who would self-identify as
machine learning don't particularly care
about they just say get a feature vector
plug it into some system
run with it the cx thing that petros was
talking about
in my experience downstream scientists
geneticists you know astronomers you
know chemists
and people that work on on neural
imaging
for them the interpretability is
paramount and so getting actual columns
really matters a lot to them
understanding where these things came
from and so you saw an example of that
we
chose a small number of actual snips
rather than a small number of eigensnips
the implicit regularization properties
i'm not going to have a lot to say about
that we've characterized it in certain
different settings and i'll allude to
some of the empirical evidence that but
not go into detail about it here
but as i said although the randomness is
inside the album gives you a worse case
guarantee
in certain cases you'll get smoother and
nicer
answers in a way that sort of
empirically is what regulation will do
you can exploit modern computer
architectures in certain certain cases
by reorganizing the steps of the
algorithm
better communication properties in
particular and that's going to be very
important for going to large scale
settings
um and if you have the data stored in
sort of external
devices so already a big story but why
do they work already a big success story
sort of why do they work what makes them
work so petra's described some of these
things and i'll go into a little bit
more detail about that
but first of all um i think the best
single afternoon i spent in the last 10
years was when i was
at doc's delicion toledo and we had
lunch and he said well michael that was
an interesting talk
um because i was talking about the least
square stuff and some other things that
i've been talking about but this stuff's
just never useful theory values people
were excited about this eight years ago
and it wasn't useful i
said i sat down with stevon at lunch and
i said um
you know i don't know whether or not
it's going to be useful you know my phd
is actually computational statistical
mechanics so i'd code eight hours a day
before i get into this stuff
and i said all the reasons why the
previous generation wasn't successful
it's clear if you've done much
implementation why they're not going to
be
and all those things are addressed here
and so maybe there'll be something else
that pops up and surprises us but um
all those reasons that it's not useful
in practice
we've addressed and so i we talked for
five hours it was going to be 15 minutes
at you know
one to one fifteen or something five
hours later was six o'clock and we went
to dinner
and eight months later i got a
manuscript on my desk that started out
with
saying um and this is not you know
a theory of algorithm's person saying
although the seva knows a lot of
theorems but he knows a lot of
scientific computing saying
randomization is arguably the most
exciting and innovative idea to hit
linear algebra in a long time
blend and pick the code that they do you
know the code that they developed in
that paper
beats la pax direct dense least squares
solver so this isn't some esoteric
problem this is just bread and butter
direct dense least squares problem
by a large margin on essentially any
tall dense matrix so it's one thing to
sort of do
um theory that sort of motivated or
might be useful it's another thing to go
head to head with
l apac if you know what that is it's
been optimized to death over the years
and beat it on essentially any tall
dense matrix and the empirical results
show the potential of random sampling
algorithms and suggests that random
projections should be incorporated into
future versions of l apac
so a remarkable claim on the applied
side for big success
so better worst case theory petrus gave
you some examples of that
implementations of bdl apec
a lot of the low rank implementations
are better so better in the sense that
they might be simpler to implement
in some cases they run faster in some
cases they're just more robust to
details of the discretization of the
grid if you're doing pde computations
other things like that
parallel and distributed implementations
i'll get back to that and a lot of
scientific applications so
why do these things work so to sort of
understand why they work or why
they didn't immediately work or why
there's a bit of a cultural disconnect
this is the result petros put up
earlier but i put in a little bit more
detail and the form of the result that
you'd see in a lot of papers will be
something like
let t sub s v d sub k time
be the time to compute an exact or
approximate rank k approximation to the
svd if you're a
numerical analyst you're probably
already getting a little bit anxious
here um
then given an arbitrary and by n matrix
there exists an algorithm
so for all you know you know this is
some existential result we can't even
write the algorithm down
um that runs in order t so we're adding
a constant there svt time depicts at
most roughly 3200 k over epsilon squared
log
k over epsilon columns such that with
probability at least 0.9
you get that result that he had up
earlier
so you know what is that that's
certainly sufficient a lot of people
will think it's necessary it's not but
you know that's some amount of time
there exists an algorithm
typically in algorithms you put the
algorithm it's a you know you may have a
constructive proof inside the proof you
basically constructed that's what's
going on here but that's not the way in
numerical analysts would think about it
3200 is a total artifact of the analysis
this was propagated to a lot of
subsequent papers that other people have
done
but if you just look at that's a total
artifact of the analysis but people get
upset about that and a little bit
concerned
and the epsilon squared you know i want
10 to the minus 10 that epsilon squared
is going to kill me
right so in a lot of cases if epsilon is
1 or 0.1 you just
sample an over extra factor of 10 or or
k plus 10
you actually do very well if you want to
drive epsilon very far down
you're going to get a large number of
effects and you're not going to be able
to do that and so if you're going to
want that you're going to have to couple
the negative algorithm we'll get back to
that
such as probability 0.9 you run this you
know
10 times in parallel keep the best this
will fail with probability
0.001 but you know it's not stated that
way
so why do these algorithms work and
essentially
the algorithms work because
they decouple the randomness from the
vector space structure so you saw an
example of this
with the cx and cyrd composition that
will petros described
also to describe what's going on hood in
terms of least squares approximations
because choosing good columns
you know with unitarily invariant norms
you can believe boils down to something
like least squares
um column subset projection what if i
want to go from k log k to exactly k
columns so this was on the slides petros
had but he didn't go into the details
but if you get a slightly stronger
structural result that he actually
described
if you have a different algorithm i want
to do a random projection and
parameterize it such that i keep k
plus 10. the analysis boils down to
exactly the same thing which in many
cases boils down to matrix
multiplication results
what if you want to work with machine
learning kernels symmetric positive
semi-definite matrices so you might
think that if you have a result for
general matrix it's going to work for a
symmetric positive semi-definite matrix
right so it's going to be a problem
there
so in most applications where you get
symmetric positive semi-definite
matrices the symmetry and positive
definition is very important
because you're not trying to get a low
rank approximation you're feeding this
into some classification system and it's
a reproducing kernel hilbert space
structure under the hood
and so you want to preserve the symmetry
and positive definition most of the
other algorithms don't do that and
that's in general going to be hard to do
right unless this matrix is diagonally
dominant or something where you have an
easy check on that
so how do you do that and so you know
you can do that if you do this to
coupling and i'll describe that
so this provides much finer control in
the application randomization to get
better worst case theory
easier to map to machine learning and
statistical ideas people that think
about parameterizing the problems
slightly differently i'll give you a
couple examples of that and
parametrizing ways that are easier to
implement
in some cases this is in the analysis
and if you look at the theory of
elements paper a lot of times this is
buried in the analysis but it's buried
there because the structural properties
per se don't matter you just want a fast
algorithm
um now there's a number of examples of
this but the simplest
example and historically the first was
these statistical leverage scores that
petrus mentioned and i'll describe this
in the context of least squares
and the interesting thing about this is
the statement of the results he had the
state of the first result i'll be doing
is we're going to run an algorithm
here's your data i'm not saying that
least squares is the right or wrong
thing to do
just run an algorithm on this and the
key non-uniformity structure that you
need to get a handle on
is something that we backed out of the
analysis but then we found out
has a very very natural statistical
interpretation in terms of regression
diagnostics and outliers
and so this is a nice example of um and
you see these same sort of structures
coming out if you do a statistical
analysis on least squares or kernel
squares so this is a nice example of
there's certain structures here and if
you have good control over them you can
get good algorithmic properties if you
ask this question good statistical
properties if you either ask that
question
or play the two against each other if
you really want to get large scale
so the best sampling algorithms
essentially use these as an important
sampling distribution
and the best projection algorithms
rotate to a random basis where they're
roughly uniform
and you really need to couple with uh
the the domain experience and that's
true whether or not you do genetics and
astronomy or numerical implementations
and so on
okay so the leverage so so let's uh
except for the symmetric positive
definite
matrices i'll be talking about
everything else will be tall let's just
go with vanilla least squares
over constrained over determined so
different areas use
a different words to describe this but
let's say that you have an n by d matrix
a
n is large d is small so it's tall
n is greater than d and let's let u
be any orthogonal matrix spanning the
column space of a
so it could be q from qr it could be u
the left singular vectors it could be
anything
and let's let u sub i
be the ith row of u so petra is
describing it in terms of
he was sampling columns because he was
doing the matrix problem so he's working
on
the left hand side of the right-hand
side here i'll be working on the
left-hand side
all right so let's let u sub i
be the ith row of u right so the columns
are unit length and orthogonal the rows
are not
and the rows can be anything right if
it's a hadamard matrix or a gaussian
with a reasonable density
the row lengths are all going to be
uniform roughly or exactly
a different orthogonal matrix could be
an identity up here with all zeros in
which case they're very non-uniform
all right and the tricky thing is if
you're in the non-uniform case not that
trivially non-uniform but more generally
the hard part for sampling algorithms is
finding these things
and if you're more familiar with signal
processing or something you should think
of this as something like a delta
function and what happens when you hit a
fourier transform against a delta
function
right you go from something that's very
localized at a single spot to very
delocalized
that's what random projections do they
take the localized structure
in the coordinate biased sense and to
localize it over all the coordinates
so the statistical leverage scores are
the euclidean norms of these
rows of u i've defined it in terms of a
particular u but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because those are the
diagonal elements of the projection
matrix under the column span of a
all right so any orthogonal matrix will
work the coherence you might be more
familiar with a lot of problems are
parametrized in terms of coherence
the coherence is the largest leveraged
score sometimes it's the largest off
diagonal element but it's the largest
leverage score and you can have cross
terms and there's going to be extensions
of this to fat matrices when
um you know the matrix is not very
rectangular but you have a low rank
parameter there'll be low rank
extensions to lp and other norms and so
on so but this is the vanilla version
right so
tall matrix diagonal is a projection
matrix
and so this is you want to bridge the
gap right between theory and practice
and algorithms and statistical for large
scale data analysis
so back in about 2005 or something
there's a range of additive error
algorithms
additive error in the sense that if you
do a sampling or projection you'd be
better than the best rank k plus epsilon
where epsilon is very large
and actually if this a lot of this work
that i'll be talking about grew
out of fear of algorithms and convex
geometry and a lot of stuff we're
hearing about here
but if you asked people back in 2005
what they thought of this line of work i
mean was it interesting useful or
whatever
if you asked anyone inside theoretical
computer science and convex analysis
they'd say i mean it's wonderful it's
beautiful we have fast algorithms
there's lower bounds i mean there's
lower bounds you can't do better than
additive
or algorithms done and wonderful if you
ask anyone basically outside theoretical
computer science
they would say either they had never
heard of it if they're being generous or
they would say they it was useless
period so so why is that and why was
there such an egregious disconnect and
now if you're eight years later why is
it the case that in fact
the original work contained a bunch of
gems of ideas but it certainly wasn't
directly useful and so now you have as i
described you know machine learning and
statistics and numerical applications
you have fast versions of random
projections relative error much stronger
numerically stable algorithms do these
computations on literally a terabyte of
data
and basically the way we bridge that gap
was by decoupling the randomness from
the linear algebra and the simplest
example is these leverage scores
so before i get to that petrol's put up
an example of genetics data
applications in astronomy astronomy
generates scubs and gobs of data
and typically they have a telescope
looks up at the sky and takes lots of
pictures right
and so you'll see something like this
here's um
here's uh continuum emission this is as
a function of frequency something having
to do with flux density
and this is something about the general
background and you'll typically see
spikes
and these spikes are either absorption
or emission lines and they say roughly
that you know you have a given thing
going on that's doing something
interesting
you have a star that's you know
oscillating in a certain way you have a
star at a certain
point and it's the evolution of its life
it was a galaxy with certain properties
you'll get dips or spikes here and there
and so an applied question that's of
interest to them
is do these computations faster because
they you know get
10 000 by million matrices you know all
the time 10 000 by 100 million matrices
and a different question is can we
select informative frequencies and the
reason you want informative frequencies
is because this frequency means a lot
you know in terms of nuclear synthesis
and stars or
means you know an awful lot in terms of
redshift properties means a lot
in terms of the physics of the problem
and what they'll oftentimes do is pull
out the first principal components and
you get an average spectrum and the
second you get some stellar continuum
the third
finer continuum plus age and then you
know you tell lots of stories because
it's just very hard to interpret beyond
the first couple eigenvectors
where think of this as 1 to 4 thousand
or nine four thousand nine thousand so
there's five thousand you're in our five
thousand
and i want to choose the most
interesting directions in that vector
space the ten most interesting um
columns
that's the spectrum those are the
principal components the first five
yeah all right so
let me talk about algorithmic approaches
to least squares i'll get back to this
astronomical example in a little bit so
tall matrix and you want to minimize uh
you want to solve that in some sense so
if you're tall in general there's not a
solution
right b has a piece sitting outside the
column space of a so it's not a solution
so what you ask for is the best such x
and
you know a standard thing to do is to
put a two norm best in the sense of
euclidean norm
so you're dealing with over constrained
lp in this case p equals two regression
problems this appears a very natural
statistical interpretation in terms of a
best linear unbiased estimator
natural geometric interpretation you
take the vector and project it down to
the span of the columns of a and so on
and so an algorithmic question is how
long does it take to solve this problem
and the short answer is it takes
n times d squared time so you can use
direct network methods and there's a
number of other subtleties there but
let's gloss over that
um at this point but you know you can
use cholesky or qr singular value
decomposition but think of it as taking
high dimension times low dimension
squared time so that's the thing you
want to beat
and then that's there's not a lot of
wiggle room right you need to touch the
high dimension
your quadratic and the low dimension a
different
question is you know you might want to
model with least squares and say when is
this the right thing to do a more
algorithmic
statistical perspective and roughly it's
when the relationship between the
outcomes and predictors
is roughly linear and the error term is
nice so you think of
a as being such that
b the right hand side is equal to ax
where x is the optimal
plus epsilon where epsilon is some error
and say it's gaussian or something else
but if it's gaussian
or nice enough that large sample theory
will hold
then this will go through so mean zero
constant variants uncorrelated roughly
normal
and so you know the prudent data analyst
machine learner will check whether these
assumptions have been
violated or how egregiously they've been
violated right and so how do you do that
so you say b is equal to ax plus noise
and you say the optimal vector x is
equal to a transpose a inverse times a
transpose b
that's what we computed couple days ago
that a couple slides ago that's n times
d squared time
and b the right hand side this is a hat
if you're familiar with hats i couldn't
get a hat in powerpoint so put a prime
there so it's a head on the front of the
head
b prime is equal to hb so h is equal to
a
times a transpose a inverse times a
transpose that's just a
complicated way of writing u times u
transpose it's just the projection
matrix under the column space of a
and in very precise senses a lot of work
in regression diagnostics it says
hij measures the influence or leverage
exerted on the ith prediction by the jth
data point
interestingly it's regardless of the
value of b since it only depends on a
and so the diagonal elements in some
sense measure the importance or
influence of a given data point
the trace of h is equal to d the low
dimension diagnostic rule of thumb if
the diagonal elements are larger than
two or three times the average value
flag it you know maybe it's an outlier
maybe you kicked the machine and you
generated the data
empirical fact in a wide wide range of
data sets you have a huge number of data
points that are factor of 10 or 20 or 50
larger than the average
and those are not mistakes those are the
most interesting data elements
and those are the outlying snips those
are the snips that are most important
for the classification axes
those are the um the frequencies that
are most interesting to the astronomers
and so you might ask why is it the case
that um in a lot of applications this
thing that should be pretty uniform if
you're doing things quote right
statistically is just very very
non-uniform
and the answer is if you think about the
snips there's no reason to think that l2
or anything like that should hold right
there's nothing gaussian about that each
snip is a single event in human history
it works its way back
with population and mixing but but then
you have a lot more snips there's
nothing gaussian about that right
so you're using an l2 computation
because you can
and even then you're going to have
trouble if you're doing it on a 10 000
by million matrix right
but anything more expensive is going to
be cancer using a computation that has
implicit assumptions that you know are
wrong and so it's not surprising that
there's going to be things that stick
out
by that measure so here's a rant here's
a vanilla
if you understand this algorithm you'll
understand you know
90 percent of the stuff that's going on
in um
these randomized matrix algorithms and
this algorithm is nice because
if you if you understand it what i said
is the case you'll understand ninety
percent of everything else
but if you wanna adopt a different
perspective and just say how does it
compare sort of on its own merits
this is an algorithm that's going to be
no faster than
a black box that i had up a couple
slides ago it's in fact going to be
epsilon worse
in terms of the objective function
quality and it might fail with
probability delta
so no faster going to be worse might
fail so it doesn't seem much to
recommend itself
um but i want to go through this in
detail because all those problems can be
solved and if you understand this this
is going to be an engine for everything
that
else that follows so we want to solve
the overconstrained least squares
problems the solution is a pseudo
inverse times b
that's just another way of writing the
same thing i put up a slide simple
algorithm
for all i and 1 to n the high dimension
compute the diagonal elements of that
projection matrix
so we only need a single score right we
don't actually need that that orthogonal
matrix but i told you to
compute it but compute that for example
by doing a qr and then reading off the
rollings but maybe you can do it faster
randomly sample something like d log d
over epsilon rows
and elements from a and b using this is
an important sampling distribution so
bias yourself towards these things
if those a uniform sample uniformly if
those are very non-uniform sample
non-uniformly
solve the sub-problem how do you solve
the sub-problem call a black box
whichever one of those things i had up a
few pages ago that you like
call in matlab relate call your favorite
black box all right
so define a non-uniformity structure sub
sample
based on that solve the sub problem you
can ask about iterating lots of things
some of the stuff in terms of structural
properties i'll get to we'll describe
some of those things but
the simplest version is just one step
define the non-uniformly structure
pull out a bunch of rows here elements
solve the sub problem
so theorem gamma is a fudge factor don't
worry about that
if you do that then both on the
objective function
and on the vector or certificate
achieving that
you're a very strong relative error so
this is the more common thing in theory
of algorithms just look at the objective
function
usually you're going to use the
certificate which you might not even
compute for more general graph
algorithms but for these machine
learning and matrix algorithm you
typically get that on
almost automatically and oftentimes
you're more interested in the
certificate because you don't really
care about the objective function you
don't care about a unitarily invariant
norm you're going to feed that vector to
some classification problem or something
so you'd like good control on that
but both on the objective function you
take x opt the solution of the sub
problem feed it back into the objective
you're within one plus epsilon of z
that's the optimum
and on the certificate your root epsilon
times the condition number
so very strong relative error
approximation of both senses of the word
naive algorithm runs in n times d
squared time but it can be improved
and this is the bottleneck as i'll point
out for the things petrus was talking
about earlier
so here's a sufficient condition
to get one plus epsilon as you want
there's your epsilon relative
approximate here's a sufficient
condition
let's let x be any pre-processing matrix
so remember what we're doing here we
have ax we're saying that
ax a is tall is close to b
and we're operating on the left hand
side because we're doing a sampling
operation we might do a projection
operation
um and and when you're operating on the
left hand side you're working on the
rows
so let's let x be the sampling operation
or the projection operation or more
generally let x be anything
all right deterministic randomized one
pass
let x be anything then for any
pre-processing matrix x
if sigma min the smallest singular value
of x
times u u of the left singular vectors
of of the matrix
is greater than a half in particular
bounded away from zero
and if u times x transpose times
x times b perp b perp is the part of b
sitting outside the column space
so u times b purp is zero if u
transpose times x transpose times x
times b perp is approximately zero if
it's less than epsilon times z squared
then you get those relative error bounds
now these are important because this is
a structural condition that decouples
the randomness from the linear algebra
there's no deterministic statement here
if x can be constructed with some
randomized mechanism great and if not do
something deterministic if you do a
deterministic thing and you can check
after the fact in an aposteriori manner
worst case algorithms people might not
like that but you may have a better
result than practice
right in particular random sampling
algorithms with leveraged score
probabilities and random projection
algorithms will satisfy that
now how does this relate to what petrols
were talking about earlier in particular
the matrix multiplication results
does this have anything to do with
matrix multiplication
but the answer is no i'm just pausing to
have a bit of water
so the answer is yes so the question is
how
so
u is an orthogonal matrix
and it's tall remember u is a is tall so
the left singular vectors are tall
u transpose u is a low dimensional
identity
all right let's look at i the identity
minus
u transpose x transpose
x u
and so the question is how far is that
from an identity
so eigen vectors and singular vectors
behave in strange ways saying you can
swing 90 degrees and so on
but a reasonable notion of closeness to
an identity is that
the spectral norm of this matrix
is less than a half or strictly less
than one you know
if it's strictly less than one than your
preserve rank so let's just say it's
bounded away from one so call it a half
if it's less than a half that's where
you get the square root there
then you preserve rank but this is just
an approximate matrix multiplication
result i mean this is a b
that's a b where b happens to equal a
all right and that's exactly the
spectral norm bound
so petros had an f we had an epsilon
here before you could have a norm
of uh a forbinius norm of a or b
depending on how it was set up he had
epsilon before because he absorbed that
into the sampling complexity
um and what's the what's the furbinius
norm of u
u is an orthogonal matrix what's the for
benious norm of u it's not the high
dimension it's not
n it's d so you call that epsilon
epsilon times d and absorb d into the
sampling complexity call that epsilon
you're done
so that first condition is a matrix
multiplication result call that as a
black box
what about the second condition
that's the first condition the second
condition so zero
is a matrix
is u transpose b perp right because b
perp is perpendicular to u
0 minus u
transpose x transpose x b perp
rabinius norm
this is a this is b
the matrix b now is a vector that's fine
for benious known as the euclidean norm
in that case
is less than epsilon times what
so to get this result remember before in
the in the matrix sampling though we
needed a sample with respect to the row
norms of a
and the row norms of b in that case you
get the cleanest results that's what we
heard before
if you sample with respect to the row
norms of just one matrix or the other
run through the analysis you get similar
results oftentimes the concentrations
worse sometimes you get
you know something that's a little bit
worse if you have a bound on
the elements of b or something then
results will go through
in this case what is b so say we sample
based on only information in a
in a meaning the left singular vectors
what is b perp
so b perp the norm of b perp is the
scale of the error we're worrying about
all right the norm of b purpose is one
of these things it's that thing it's a
scale
it's the amount of mass sitting outside
the column space of a so we just eat
that
so it's epsilon times the norm of the
forbinius norm of u
which is uh k or what am i doing d
root d times b perp and that's to get
those results
so this is a matrix multiplication
result get a nice structural result
characterization here call matrix
multiplication black box done
all right so yeah
well so what i mean i can give a couple
examples it's not that you should
understand that
um i'd like to make statements
i i'd like to apply what what i don't
want to do
because you just get results that are
too coarse is think of this as
a random projection johnson
lindenstrasse and just whack it i mean
that works in any metric space if you
apply it in rn you're going to do a lot
of damage
because it's a much more structured
place so you can do that
and in fact if you do that with a random
projection and you close your eyes you
get out of our bounds only
years later the people went back and
looked inside the analysis of geez in
fact you can get much better results
it was only after in the column sampling
we said what's the basic structure
results in the vector space that's going
to be sufficient to get good bounds
and what if we apply randomness right
there and sometimes that's
done in the algorithm use smart sampling
problems rather than dome sampling
probabilities
and you apply it inside the algorithm
meaning inside the algo you have to
compute those probabilities it could be
inside the analysis do a random
projection
and at this step of the analysis i say
i'm going to bound this thing in a smart
way or this thing in a coarser way
so if you just view it in terms of i
think in terms of a johnson source type
result you're going to get much closer
results
than if you understand the vector space
structure and so and so what i mean is
i want to get sort of sufficient
conditions that are deterministic that
don't have any statement about
randomness
and then i want to show that for certain
classes of random matrices
sampling or projection there i get good
results
so there's a couple reasons why that's
the case one if you're just in worst
case bounds
it's a cleaner ammo in in terms of
trying to get that two is
you know what if i don't want to sample
you know what am i calling it d
what if i don't want to sample d log d
over epsilon what if i want to sample d
plus 10
if i have a way to check whether those
are satisfied
then i can sample d get d plus 10. if
the answer is yes done if the answer is
no
choose another 10. and so it's a way
doing this
it's a way to parameterize the problems
in cleaner ways
that are going to be more amenable to
numerical analysis into statistical
analysis to the way people outside
algorithms formulate problems
so does that make sense
so this is one example i'll give you
another example a couple slides later
and let's talk offline i mean it it's
not a precise statement it's it's an
informal statement but this is an
example of it i'll give you a couple
another example in a couple slides
but i want i want i guess my problem is
i don't see the larger picture i mean i
don't see the
i don't have the prerequisites like you
could be there if i do a projection
oftentimes it's inside the analysis
if i do a sampling it's in the results
it's it's it's in the algorithm
so if i do a projection it's did i say
that right if i do a projection it may
be inside the analysis
so so for example to get the additive
error bounds that i alluded to before
what was done you know 15 years ago is
sample according to the euclidean norms
of the rows of a
or you could do a random projection and
apply johnson lindenstrasse
basically on the rows of a
and you've got an added variables in
both cases now i could also
say what if i sampled in in a more
sophisticated way based on the leverage
scores
now do johnson lindenstrasse basically
on those things the rows of the right or
left singular vectors
so now it's it's inside the algorithm
because i've had the sample in a
different way
if i do a random projection the
algorithm is exactly the same do a
random projection but now inside the
analysis i say geez don't apply johnson
linustraws on the rosa matrix
but apply johnson linden straws on the
rows of the right or left singular
vectors so this is buried inside the
analysis
but for the same things going on
do you worry about the computational
cost to check these conditions
um for the
regression case no but one could um
because it we can guarantee it and so on
and so forth for the low-rank case the
answer is yes so the
some of the good high-quality numerical
implementations won't
sample in that case if you have a rank
parameter k log k
uh but they'll they'll they'll um
they'll sample k
plus 10 and then they'll have a check to
say did i preserve rank and so
and a way to do that is to check to a
rank revealing qr or something so they
those implementations uh do in fact
check the
generalization of these conditions
i guess it means that in the analysis
you are decoupling
in the analysis if i can if i can show
that this is the case then i'm done
and one one way to do this would be
choose a randomized algorithm
namely choose a random x a random
mapping x and show that i satisfy that
with high probability
so lemma if you satisfy this you get
relative error
that's level one limit two random
samplings with this
leveraged squares random projection
satisfies that combine them done yeah
so this is just a deterministic
statement independent of any randomness
that talks about how
the sketching operator interacts with
the vector space structure
for yeah this at some point under the
use of condition
so to the extent that i can understand
some of the papers yes
but it's oftentimes very deep in the
analysis and if you ask the people who
wrote those papers they'll say yes but
it's not exactly clear where in the
analysis
so in a sense this is just clarifying
something that
i think on the algorithm side people
just don't worry about because the goal
is not to understand these properties
per se the goal is just a fast algorithm
and just bury it all in the analysis but
um
in i don't know of an exception to it
but in most or all cases
something like this is buried in the
analysis but i mean it
that's one of the things that makes it
impenetrable to people one step removed
from albums but
um i think so yeah
okay a little bit more interpretation of
the intuition the second
the second condition
so essentially what we're doing here
this is a high dimensional space it's n
dimensions
and i want i mean there's you know you
can define a notion of an angle between
two lines you can define a notion of an
angle between two subspaces
and um what this is saying is that if
you dot
u into itself you know things exactly
align in nice ways and you get exactly
an identity
all the singular values are on what this
says is if i if i take this
you i mean think of this in terms of
numbers right if you have a million
numbers
um and you sample from them then you
know if the variance isn't too bad you
sample a couple hundred you get a good
estimate
i mean this is saying exactly that right
if this is a matrix multiplication
result this is just saying exactly that
but in terms of the vector space
structure your if you write these out as
rank one operators
then you can think of each of these
things as mapping to a particular
component in the high dimensional space
and so we're doing we're sampling a
small number of rows you know
constraints
um and we're saying that we're going to
do sort of a rotation from the n
dimensions
and we're not just doing some arbitrary
rotation up and then dimensions we're
doing a rotation in n dimensions that
goes down here and zeroes out the vast
majority of things
but that rotation that zeroed out the
vast majority of things
has a small angle so preserving rank is
basically saying that the angle between
the two subspaces is small
so i'm here i rotate in a very careful
way that zeroes out most of the things
and that angle's small in the high
dimensional space and that's the
interpretation of both
but in particular the ladder yeah
all right um so i told you
don't worry about the fact that the
algorithms n times d squared time and
all these sorts of things why
um so this is a basic structural result
so the question is how do you what you
want to do with this and what you want
to do with this really depends on
whether you're in ram whether there's
flops whether you're
optimizing flops whether you're
optimizing something in parallel
distributed
etc etc if you want to optimize things
in ram
if you want to be fastest in terms of
just flop count operation count
you can use a fast random projection and
by that i mean basically a fourier or
hadamard type structured random
projection so
the first examples was alliance chazelle
when they were interested in um
a problem related to this and um so i
was applying it to the least squares
problem and a whole bunch of other
people have followed up on that
and it's you should think of this as as
something like a gaussian random
projector plus minus one random
projection
but it's structured so you can take
advantage of fast fourier techniques and
in particular
you can apply it in n log d time roughly
so not nd n log d and there's an extra
factor of d to take care of every
every uh column and so roughly it's nd
log d
time so do a random projection and
roughly nd log d
time faster than nd squared solve the
sub problem
or call an algorithm to approximate the
leverage scores
that's a black box i'll get to that in a
few slides
the bottleneck in that black box is a
random projection
which takes exactly the same time and d
log d time
so fast random projection pre-processed
with this fast
hadamard base random transform that
rotates to
a random basis of the leverage scores of
uniform sample uniformly done
solve the sub problem or compute one
plus epsilon approximations with a black
box i'll describe in a little bit the
running time of which is a random
projection
solve the sub problem if you do either
of those you get one plus a minus
epsilon approximations
in nd i said log d it's in fact n d log
of d log n over epsilon plus d cubed in
lower terms
all right this is good if you want
epsilon to be 0.1
not if you want absolutely 10 to the
minus 10 if you want n epsilon 10 to the
minus 10 i guess i don't have it
basically you take that sketch you did
rather than that feed that to a black
box that
solves the sub problem use that as a
pre-conditioner
call a traditional iterative method
all right use it as a pre-conditioner
you get a well-conditioned system
you don't need iterate too much so
that's what blend and pick did blend in
pick
is um the quote that i put up earlier
and i'll talk about how to do that same
sort of idea in a in parallel or
distributed environments and that's lsrn
um
before this must be an algorithms guy
that loves about like this right
this is going to be makeup i know i know
so
what makes you think is there any
evidence that it can be as fast you can
i can replace that with constant times
the number of non-zeros
50 times 10 times the number of
non-zeros
ends large
so if the number of non-zeros has to be
linear in n you have rows that are zero
number of non-zeros is better than nd
it's more than nd by number of non-zeros
i understand that i'm still trying to
get a term which is like this function
of n and then some
you want what do you want to remove this
log so so the clarkson woodruff result
that
the the genre extended so i mean does
this in sparsity so that's the constant
times number of non-zeros but you're
asking something
different you're saying that for example
i don't need
n times d right i can replace with the
number of zeros yeah
we don't know how that feeds it or
iterators and so on but this but yeah
i mean that's that's that's currently
theoretical result we and others i think
petrus has an implementation we have
something but
and it performs well we haven't done
high precision but yeah we can replace
that with constant time but non-zero
um feed it to an iterative algorithm
i'll mention later you know
roughly how you do it but if you
understand the basic idea we have here
depending on time i can go through that
in 10 minutes or one
and you'll understand the basic idea
even if i do it in one if you understand
the basic idea what we've done
so far so is it clear to everyone what
we've done so far
just one song is a square and the
sufficient statistic is just a
covariance matrix that's why it's truly
paralyzable
then the essentially we can just quickly
calculate this d
square d by d correspondence then
calculate things and that's essentially
what
was done with the snip data you have a
high dimension
um
oh okay so now the algorithmic point it
doesn't matter you just
sometimes it does depending on how the
different levels of blast are
implemented but it doesn't matter
if we just want to calculate coherence
matrix right truly paralyzed
right then we don't need to worry about
that very big end and just to get that
smaller
d square coherence matrix then fitted
into whatever big square solver
um maybe you still need to compute
that problem and that's going to defend
the name right
the covariance matrix for that quantity
i'm doing in some sort of
parallel or distributed way so the
answer is yes i guess the question is
how exactly going to implement that your
shared memory or not
and that's what the stuff towards the
end you know either you're an apparel or
distributed type environment and
you need to if it's not shared memory
you need to aggregate resources back and
mapreduce
is one way to do it certainly not the
best for these iterative algorithms
we've with the l1 regression on terabyte
was mapreduce and it was harder than
doing least squares because it was l1
but
yeah that's what we did
no just l1 on the objective
yeah yeah
yeah so that's the thing that we have on
the terabyte and mapreduce essentially
is there a deterministic sub nd squared
algorithm
um to get one deterministic
sub nd squared not that i know of i mean
aside from stress or something like that
but
not that i know is there
so that's one of these cultural
disconnects so he's repricing flops but
if if
long answer so so depending on what
you're counting flops or memory accesses
and so on
the statement of this doesn't deal with
any of that basically
how you do if you don't want to
implement these ideas
how whether you're going to put it in
ram or in a parallel distributed setting
you need to start worrying about those
issues
and the basic thing is take this meta
algorithm this meta procedure
and instantiate in different ways if
you're going to put it in ram optimize
flops if you're going to put it in
parallel should it optimize that
standard
mode yeah that that i don't know so the
answer
jim gave doesn't address the standard
ram model vanilla flops thing
it has with memory access if you
couldn't hear that when you say standard
ram you're saying
every everything is equally expensive
to a plop in the memory access in that
case you wouldn't probably
use these algorithms these are
especially interesting the matrices so
that they don't fit
so yeah we have to have the right cost
model here
but one of the lessons better cost
models we need to figure out for
algorithms right
and i agree totally yeah
all right um
so in astronomy the the application
where there's
this we apply this basically um lick
indices are
are a set of indices it's this frequency
regime that frequency regime
a lot of manual effort depending on you
know knowing this astronomy the question
is can you come up with them in a more
sort of objective way and the short
answer is yes basically
you know you can identify the outlying
leverage scores and use a reasonable
heuristic to spread the lines and and
you can get um
something like this that if i had the
full picture will correlate very
strongly with with the lick indices so
the old look indices are reasonably ad
hoc when i when i say this sort of thing
the question is who who's evaluating you
are you sending this to some
um someplace that doesn't know anything
about astronomy or you're sending this
to the astrophysical journal
and and so this is in a revision it's
not just submitted so this is send it to
astronomical or astrophysical journal
because they're particularly in the
downstream application and the
informative reasons are roughly
orthogonal to the lick industries
to each other in contrast with look
indices that's good for certain
applications
in astronomy potentially it'll recover
the atomic lines and molecular bands and
so on
in sort of a reasonably principled way
at least uh
in the sense of the astronomers felt so
let me move on to a statistical
perspective and then i'll
yeah yeah i don't understand what does
experiments show approximately
what this shows is that you can use this
algorithm on small data if you want to
do the expensive computation
on larger data if you want to do the
approximate approximation algorithm to
compute the leverage scores that i'll
put up in a few slides
to compute things like this that
maybe no one in this room cares about
but that if this was a room full of
astronomers they'd be interested in
and we have at least one i care we have
at least one
good and it was there is is there two or
three
okay all right i just want to make sure
i understand the point right
if i had a time is not a constraint i
can do
exactly this question i'll get some
results if time is not a constraint if
they get
approximately this question i get
similar quality of results or something
and then you can tell me that running
time matters
i just want to make sure so from an
algorithmic perspective the non-uniform
structure you want in this case is the
leverage scores
if if you're not so approximate them or
project to uniformize them
those things are interesting because
they correlate strongly with regions of
the genome that are interested to
geneticists
regions of the frequency spectrum that
are interest to astronomers regions of
the brain that are interested in
neuroscientists so
in the neuroscience context i have the
impression that unless that means
something would be
in the fat algorithm case and where n is
where n is large in the hundred thousand
range and
d is in the hundred to two hundred
uh actually i'm sorry
the opposite right because we have we
have short time
series a couple hundred points but we
have a hundred thousand of them or two
hundred thousand of them
and we do want to pick individuals so we
don't want to transport that thing
what matters is which are the individual
voxels that are sort of highlighted if
you want to sample the small dimension
excuse me you want a sample in the small
dimensions yeah so you could you could
extend this
and um i'm not going to go into the
details but basically
arbitrary m by n matrix you need a rank
parameter choose that however that's a
model selection rule that
is outside the discussion we're talking
about define the leverage scores
relative
to the best rank k space that's actually
the low rank thing on in genetics
we didn't we didn't look at the uh at
400 people in hat map or 4 000 in the in
the extensions that we looked at the
best rank 10 or 20 approximation
yeah and in the same way as the spectrum
decay slowly and this never kinks the
way people sort of think about it
the leverage scores behave in
complicated ways and so on and that's
there's a bit of an art there and a bit
of a practice
yeah all right so let me um
briefly mention a statistical
perspective so basically what
would i've said and it's the case if
you're in worst case algorithms this
this is a structure you need to find
if you're going to do low rank
approximation you need some extensions
of that structure so petrus gave an
example earlier
where it had to do with the top part of
the spectrum multiplied by the sampling
matrix
basically by the pseudo inverse of the
sampling matrix operating on the right
singular vector so that's a
generalization of that so some structure
like that
the question is how is this thing going
to perform in practice statistically
so we see in a lot of cases actually is
that
whether or not we need to if we run an
approximation algorithm for say the
leverage scores
um and we use that approximation as a
proxy rather than the exact one
oftentimes you'll do better
clearly not on the objective function um
but you'll do better in some downstream
sense like the astronomical genetic
sense
for people who don't know or care about
what we're talking about they want to
use this stuff as a black box
and so why is that the case
sort of informally i think why that's
the case is you have randomness inside
the algorithm
and you're not exactly fitting to this
particular data set so you're not
exactly fitting the non-uniformly
structured in this data set you're
smudging it out a little bit and that's
particularly true not in the very
rectangular case
but in symmetric positive semi-definite
case or or or
just general m by n matrix we have a low
rank parameter so you're not fitting
exactly to this data set you're smudging
it out a little bit so you're
effectively implicitly uh folding
regularization into the algorithm
so if you really drove epsilon down to
10 to the minus 10 you're getting the
exact answer
in fact it's better to leave epsilon as
point one or even one and get a much
coarser approximation
so can you formalize that so um
we formalize this this is a thing on
venue and i've switched
notation because you know the hard part
is figuring out that when you're talking
about x you're talking about the matrix
that i was calling a before
so statisticians say y is equal to x
beta plus epsilon
so for the next few slides i'm going to
use that notation but it's the same over
constrained least squares that
we're talking about beta ordinarily
squares is the argument that's the thing
we had before
why i still call this h leverage score
is still the same
main algorithm randomly sample now we're
n by p
i've got change the d to a p so now
we're n by p
i'm using the exact or approximate
leverage scores as the important
sampling distribution
down sample and rescale the way you
heard about before solve the sub problem
so from a worst case sense
biasing yourself towards these
non-uniformity structure either
explicitly inside the algorithm or
implicitly by doing a random projection
is uniformly better
than uniform sampling just period right
you can very easily construct examples
where uniform will just fail how does
that perform in in practice so let's
consider uniform sampling
let's consider sort of a vanilla version
of leverage with exact leverage scores
approximately the same unless you do
rough approximations in this particular
context
and what i'll call shrink leverage which
is roughly use the leverage scores and
it mix in a little bit of something a
little bit of uniform
in this particular case but you can
implement that algorithmically in kernel
cases
just by running the approximation
algorithm and something else where i'm
going to sample
and not reweight and this will be
introducing bias in a certain form
so how is this going to perform so the
estimator beta
which is the x opt i had before beta is
this messy expression the point is that
there's the x matrix
and there's the scaling and resampling
matrix w which depends on whether you're
doing this
uniformly or non-uniformly so you get
some expression there which is a little
bit messy and which is going to be hard
to analysis on so let's do
essentially a taylor expansion of this
solution
around a point so what's around which
point and basically it's around in this
case an all ones vector because the
expectation of the
relating vector is going to be around is
is going to be one
if you don't rescale you need to do
expansion around something else i'm not
going to go into the details of that
but we'll see later that you're going to
introduce a very systematic bias
and then beta for
this omega is either uniform or leverage
or approximate leverage or
strength leverage or whatever is the
beta ordinary least squares
plus this term plus other stuff so it's
the leading thing that you'd expect plus
some other stuff
x transpose x inverse times diagonal of
e something linear
in w which is the sampling and scaling
probabilities plus higher order terms
and what you can show very easily
dilemma of the following form
expectations of beta
hat for any sampling process
in which you do the rescaling the way
we've been talking about it so far
is going to be ordinary least squares
plus something small
now whether that's that's something
smaller not actually i'm going to get
back to but plus a higher order
something that you hope is a higher
order term
and this is conditioned on a given
matrix on a given data set
now that's a very natural way to think
about in terms of algorithms if you're a
statistician you might want to be
thinking about is not conditional on a
given data set but the fact that i ran
i have a given model and i instantiate
the given data set a bunch of different
times
because it's generated from a random
process so you might also ask i want
the result unconditional i want the
expectation and variance unconditional
on the data
so here you have an expectation and
you're not
unbiased around the ordinary least
squares estimate you're estimated around
let's call it beta naught
this is the ground truth right if you
have a model you say the data generated
according to this ground truth
i get a particular snapshot of the data
and i get ordinarily squares estimate
if you condition on the data that's what
you'd get if you don't condition on the
data you get the ground truth
and in both cases you get a variance the
details of the variance terms are a
little bit different
but the point is that you're going to
have something x transpose x inverses on
both sides
with a sandwich expression diagonal e's
times the diagonal of something having
to do with the inverse probabilities
right because we needed to do the
resampling and
sorry when we did the sampling we needed
to do the scaling earlier and we needed
to do the scaling
because we want the sampled version of u
transpose u to be on the same scale as
the identity
all right if you sample 100 points out
of a million
you uniformly rescale everything by a
million over 100.
this is just the non-uniform version of
that
and you get a slightly different but you
still have a sandwich expression but
still it's sandwich expression in the
unconditional case
so let's ask how these things so uniform
sampling so it depends the question is
going to be
the two parameters we're going to have
to play with here is 1 r the number of
samples
2 pi is going to be the probability
distribution that you sample and rescale
with respect to
so uniform the variance is going to
scale as n over
r high dimension divided by the number
of samples if your statistician that's
probably very familiar
if you do a leveraged estimate the
variance is going to scale as p over r
when i say scale
means you're going to have something
here plus all this other stuff but the
leading order term the scaling on it
is going to be either n over r that's
going to be awkward algorithm because
that's suggested if you sample
50 n columns you're going to get good
results right and you want to be
sampling
n over 50 columns the basic leverage is
p
over r that's good because it suggested
if you sample p log p low dimension log
low dimension that's going to be small
but you have one over the leverage
scores as the ham inside your sandwich
right you know and if the large scores
are very small you might be in trouble
that's not a problem from
the worst case perspective but from the
statistical perspective it's going to be
it turns out if you had mixed in a bit
of of uh
you you shrink them back a little bit
you heard the shrinkage um yesterday and
mike was talking about one particular
form of it you can get the variance to
scale as p over r
and you can remove basically the one
over leveraged terms in the denominator
not that you remove them but they're all
not too far from uniform they want the
no worse than one-tenth uniform
um you can also remove these rescalings
exogenously just don't rescale and you
can say how does that perform
and we'll see that that performs better
or worse depending on the question you
ask
um if you generate matrices the
left-hand side is is
gaussian data yeah so you have uniform
leverage scores it's all the same if you
use t1 or something where there's a
non-uniform distribution
the variance is on the number of samples
is on the x-axis here variance is on the
y
bias is on the y straight line is
leverage
dotted line is uniform leverage is just
better right so this
would be better now the question about
losing rank is an interesting one
because here
in the worst case analysis you need to
preserve rank done or you're dead
right what's the way to measure quality
here i'm talking about bias and variance
essentially i'm talking about mean mse
right
is that the right way to view this or
not it turns out that if you
if you try to optimize the mean squared
error the right sampling probably not
the leverage scores but it's something
like
the row lengths which is what you got
the old additive error algorithms the
results that are worse from an
algorithmic perspective it's not exactly
the row lengths but to first order it's
going to be the roll lengths
so that suggests it's going to be a
trade-off between the bias and variance
here and you see that
so what we see here is the log of the
variance
and the log of the bias from 0 to say
500 and
this is just zoomed in 0 to 50. the
point is here that the bias is not going
to be monotonic
as a function of the number of samples
effectively because
if you sample with the dashes uniformly
you may lose rank
if you sample with the leverage scores
you will not lose rank now what i mean
by that
if you choose your parameters right and
the x-axis is 10 if you choose
20 you know 10 log 10 over x but if you
choose 20 columns
according to the leverage distribution
you can show that you will not lose rank
you need to get up to order 500 with
with the uniform sampling
and i guess i took that slide out of the
deck or here it is so the fraction of
singular sub problems will be something
like
um you know if you get down this is the
proportion of singularities
if you use leveraging very quickly the
number of samples is going to go to zero
which is exactly is exactly that result
but if you do it uniformly
you need to sample half the column
something something just much much
larger
but if you lose rank it's not
necessarily a bad thing in terms of the
mse
because if you've lost a lot of rank
you're on one or two dimensions you're
just going to have a lot less variation
so whether the mscs are the right or or
not right the way to
view this from assistive perspective is
a separate question but that's just one
example illustrating sort of the
subtleties that if you adopt the worst
case perspective you're going to get one
set of results
from a statistical perspective you want
to bias yourself towards the leverage
scores or not you're going to get a
different set of results potentially
but we can use these shrink leverage
scores algorithmically the running time
is going to be no worse
because you just approximate the
leverage scores and then you know
add a little bit of basal level of
something uniform
and statistically you're going to get
better properties and let me gloss over
the um
the bias with the unweighted just sort
of into the interest of time
all right so the statistical thing i
went through quickly is there any sort
of questions
at a high level on that
all right so the point there is that if
you're going to
be interested in the statistical
properties these are sort of the
relevant structures
but you may get better or worse answers
depending on the worst
depending on the questions you're asking
then you would set it from a worst case
perspective
i think there's going to be a lot of
questions here to say you know what if
you want to
introduce bias in a different way what
if rather than solving the sub problem
that's a least squares problem you solve
a biased version of the sub problem you
might you might get a better estimator
of the original problem right i'm saying
solve a sub problem
i'm saying construct a sketch solve a
sub problem you may solve a different
sub problem
and be able to introduce bias in a
slightly better way and play off the
bias variance tradeoff in a better way
than you do here mse is probably not the
best metric to look at these things
through because basically it's going to
be a variance metric
and you're going to gloss over a lot of
the subtleties that you see here
but you can get better statistical
properties in the least squares case and
i'm not going to turn that
but you can do it also in the kernel
case in other cases like that
all right so let's talk about extending
these ideas to kernels and symmetric
positive semi-definite matrices
and the motivation here is going to be
that you want to extract a linear
structure from data
but the data might not be naively linear
so there's a lot of machinery
on basically using symmetric positive
semi-definite matrices so so-called
kernels
to basically extract a linear structure
in an implicitly defined feature space
algorithmically you're going to get
a symmetric positive semi-definite
matrix this is interesting
in a lot of cases in the matrix is
reasonably well approximated by
something low rank
the n squared times the rank parameter
and cube computation may be
too expensive can you do something
faster
so
the prior work here was just very very
weak and i know that because it was
actually based on a result that i had
with
petros about seven years ago where we
got additive error bounds
but it was this very very weak additive
area it was the editor wasn't even the
scale of the matrix
the added error was basically the scale
of the square root of the matrix
and we had this sort of sample in a very
naive way and and the tricky part was
that
it wasn't clear how to preserve the
symmetry in positive definiteness
there's been a lot of work following up
on that um
but i think it's fair to say that you
know our results but all the subsequent
work really was sort of
sufficiently weak that it wasn't even a
qualitative guide to practice
and there's a lot of questions about is
projections or sampling of this or that
the right way to view it and
and um sometimes you'll have a data set
that you do marginally better on with a
projection
or some version of sampling and so we
tried to take a step back and say you
know what's going on here
um and this is in spite of the fact that
you know these these nitrogen-based
methods are just used in a lot of
applications
and you know with some success there's
also was a lot of conflicting claims
about uniform sampling versus leverage
based sampling you know
what do real data look like you know are
is the coherence small is is these
things
pretty non-uniform um and and
some claims that sort of a lot of
machine learning applications you just
had low coherence this contrasted very
very sharply with
um the sort of proven non-uniformity of
these things in genetics and astronomy
and a range of other applications it was
really of interest to downstream
practitioners
and the other reason we're revisiting
this now is now there's a lot of high
quality implementations that there
wasn't before
so um just to remind you spectral for
benious and trace norms
these are matrix norms measure the size
of the matrix
that are related in this way and the
basic symmetric positive semi-definite
sketching model will be the following
say i have a as an n by n positive
semi-definite matrix
and s is my sketching matrix it's this
thing but i'm going to think of it as a
sketching matrix
and then i'm going to call c the sample
of columns
from a and w is the intersection
so you can think of s as a sampling
matrix in which case you're sampling
actual columns or a projection matrix or
anything else
and the key insight here this is with
alex kittens and the key insight he had
was that if you work within the
structure of this particular form
then effectively you're implicitly
inside the analysis you're implicitly
working on the square root of the
of the original symmetric positive
semi-definite matrix
so now as long as you respect that
structure
then you're always going to be
guaranteed something of the form that's
going to be symmetric and positive
semi-definition so you can run through
the analysis
and how do we do that well we had to
come up with results that essentially
decoupled the randomness from the vector
space structure
in a slightly different way and this
just provided much finer control in
these applications in a range of
examples
so here's an example here's so the basic
example so say that your a is a
symmetric positive semi-definite matrix
u 1 is the top k eigenvalues omega 1
is the sketched version of the top kagan
values
and i didn't write it down but u2 is the
bottom n minus k eigenvalues
and omega 2 is the bottom n minus k so
use 1 and 2 is the top and bottom part
of the spectrum
u is the eigenvalues omega is the
sketched version of the eigenvalues
so this is a deterministic structural
result
when c is a s the sample of columns or
the sketch of the columns it doesn't
need to be a sample
and w is s transpose a x
then if you take your original matrix a
and you approximate it with a
symmetric positive semi-definite matrix
c times a pseudo inverse of w times c
transpose this is
this is a symmetric positive
semi-definite version of a c-u-r
decomposition if you know what that is
um and we're interested in spectral and
for benious and trace and you might
expect
that you're going to it's going to be
harder to get good results for spectral
norm than for venus or trace and we'll
see that in the analysis
then you're going to be better than the
best rank k
that's the best rank k approximation day
just a different way of writing it
in spectral or for being as a trace plus
some other stuff
and that other stuff depends on how good
the sketch is not surprisingly
right that other stuff depends on how
the bottom part of the spectrum
talks to the top part of the spectrum in
particular talks to the inverse of the
pseudoin versus the top part of the
spectrum so if this sketch was just an
identity you keep all the columns or i
guess i shouldn't say an identity but
but
the top k columns the the the top kagan
vectors
then the bottom part of the spectrum
namely this rotation i'm talking about
was not a rotation the angle is zero
then
the top part of the spectrum and the
bottom part of the spectrum are
perpendicular
they don't talk to each other that term
is zero the scaling here is square root
of
sigma versus sigma but it wouldn't
matter if they're exactly perpendicular
that term would be zero and all those
terms would drop
but if you're doing a sampling or
sketching the question is how good is it
and the
answer to how good is it is it is as
good as the best
plus something that depends on how the
sketch talks to the vector space
structure
assuming omega has full rank assuming
omega one has full rank
for the forbidden spectral norm that's i
mean if they're completely perpendicular
that's true from the traditional terms
right but
yeah trace maybe yeah
so how do we guarantee that omega 1 has
full rank
this is just a full rank the full matrix
version of this
to guarantee that that has low rank
you look at the leverage scores in the
top k space sample the spec to them
if s is a sampling matrix
or if s is a projection matrix you
choose the parameter right k log k
and you guarantee that so that
assumption is automatically satisfied
assuming you set this thing up the right
way and then you have to control all
these terms talk to each other and it's
not immediately obvious that
those will be small but it will turn out
that they will be right so this is a
basic structural result
and once you have this you can say you
know how does the sampling of
projections
how do they behave and the answer is in
this is much much better than the
previous theory i'll put up the previous
theory before
but you're also at a level of
granularity where the differences
between
what we you can prove with the sampling
based methods and what you can do with
the projection based methods if you use
plus minus one projections
and what you can do with the projection
based methods if you use gaussian
projections
starts to reveal more about the analysis
you have on
on on the control of those things than
how the results
actually would be and or how they'd
perform in in a real application
so on an exercise i'll give you an
example of that there's going to be
various terms because we parameterize it
two different ways
and the an open question is you know
given that there's still going to be a
theory practice gap can you
can you start to improve some of those
things so say s is a sampling matrix
where you sample with the exact
approximate leverage source
a minus the low rank approximate is best
rank k plus epsilon
times something that's large the trace
norm is larger than the spectral
for the frobenius you get one plus
epsilon
best plus epsilon times something and
for trace you actually get relative
error
if you have a projection matrix the
parameters are you know we parameterize
it slightly differently but it's best
rank k
plus something times trace additive with
scale
given by trace best rank k plus
slightly different uh additive but scale
is still given by trace
and one plus epsilon and similar bounds
for gaussian
if you want to do a coherence based
analysis you get the same sort of stuff
but you have to eat a factor of the
coherence and so on and so forth
um so uh
let me gloss over that if anyone's
interested in how the data actually look
grab me afterwards and i'll tell you
because there's some subtleties there
and say you know before you had a minus
the same approximation was better than
best rank k
plus epsilon times the sum of the
diagonal entries in a which is large
this is
pretty large kumar and mori and tal
walker had a result that says if you
sample k log k times something that
depends on the coherence
columns uniformly and if a has exactly
rank
k then you can reconstruct a and giten's
had sort of a soft version of this
that says you can do this if the matrix
is an exactly rank k where he had
spectral norm approximations
that were either best rank k plus 1
times 1
plus 2 n over l which is not so good if
you want l to be
1 100 of n which is what you typically
want but that's you're going to be stuck
with something large
that's either multiplying the base
factor or is tacked on as a relatively
large
additive scale and then and we see that
in our methods
um so let me gloss over that again and
say
how do we approximate the leverage
scores quickly and i'm going to give you
the vanilla algorithm
in the tall case and the same ideas will
go through with a few more subtleties in
the case of general matrices
in particular the symmetric positive
semi-definite ones i've been talking
about
so here's the algorithm it's simpler
than it looks the algorithm is going to
be basically the following
i have a matrix a it's tall
multiply it by let's call it pi as a
random projection
so again pi can be a subsampled
randomized
hadamard transform if you want to
optimize flops it can be gaussian if you
want a better communication properties
it can be
you know whatever but think of it if
you're optimizing flops in terms of the
uh
you know fast johnson linen trust type
methods so if you have a and you do qr
on a
then i can post multiply a by r and i
get q
read the row lengths off that those are
the things i want right once i have that
read the row lengths off those that's a
non-uniformly structure i want
so let's look at this and let's say do
qr
on pi a all right
and then let's say i do
i a r inverse is equal to q
now two different queues here so maybe i
should say cube q title or something
an r title so this q
is optimal for pi a right i get
a good q for pi a but i can take this r
inverse
and go back here and if i take a and
look at our title inverse
i get a matrix q title title
the dimensions are all right i'm not
going through the details of the
dimensions
that's tall and i can read the row norms
off of that
if i want to get one any one leverage
score that's is sufficient
and if i want to get them all i need to
put a second projection there
um and uh i preserve distances to one
plus epsilon and so i can preserve the
leverage squares one plus epsilon it all
goes through so basically
do a random projection on a running time
is random projection time
do qr and work with a
our inverse multiplied by a second
projection
then you're projecting on the small
dimension not the large dimension
usually we project on the large
dimension but here i'm projecting on the
small dimension
and i get a bunch of numbers you have a
tall matrix and i'll just read them off
i get a bunch of numbers and numbers in
fact
and those numbers are relative our
approximations to the corresponding
leverage scores so i get l
title i such that l
title i the approximation is within one
plus epsilon
of l i which is defined to be this um
you know this
quantity i had all right and that runs
in
this time which is the n d log root d
plus all these other factors i don't
know if mu is still here but these are
the factors he was asking about so you
know in nd log d time
um the running time is good if you want
to get into
large problems um in in the sense that
basically the running time is going to
be the same as it was for blend and pick
you know so it'll be faster than um than
l a pack for large matrices where large
is very modest
so a couple hundred by a couple thousand
so very modest sense of the word large
and up two thousands by a billion or
whatever
um the stuff that i was telling you and
the parallel and distributed
environments works
what if you this actually gets back to
the statistical perspective i was
talking about
what if you um you know you work in r
you don't want to get
hugely large and you want to say how
does this perform
this was when we were work this is one
piece of the um
statistical perspective i was talking
about ping mod did this he's a
statistician
not a numerical guy not an algorithms
guy and i said why don't you compute
this
and he said how i said here's the
vanilla version how does it implement an
r so you should think of this as being a
model for what
someone that might want to do that just
pulls something off the shelves uses one
of these algorithms instead of a vanilla
form not a very sophisticated high
quality numerical implementation
and here we're n by p again so fix
p to be whatever the size is the sample
size n goes from
i think p was 2 000 or something the
sample size n goes from something
up to 60 or 70 000. fixed end to be i
think was 20 000 in the small dimension
went from a couple hundred to five
thousand
and let's say that we do this projection
wherever i have the projection this
projection right here
and don't even be smart about it don't
do the fast hadamard based things but do
a plus minus one random projection
and do a gaussian projection and even be
sloppy
and don't do this second projection
so do something here it's not fast in
terms of flops
this gets the jim's point jim left but
this gets the gems button this isn't
going to be faster in terms of plop so
we're not going to do the second
projection there to be better in theory
and what we see is the following call qr
try and solve the least square sub
problem
this is the running time on one of the
figures that i glossed over a few
minutes ago and what you see the
algorithm behaves this way it's linear
in the dimension n
and it's slightly worse gets b fast and
g faster the binary and gaussian
and exact is the two types of random
projections the the dark line is the
exact
a little bit faster gets a little bit
slower so you know you're 20 faster so
that's good or not depending on whether
you care about
these things but you can get from thirty
five thousand up to sixty thousand
so sixty thousand is large in a modest
sense of the word but
you can get almost a factor of two
larger similarly on the predictor size p
n was as i said i think twenty thousand
this you can get the small dimension
with the exact algorithm up to about
whatever that is thirty five hundred you
can get up to about five thousand or a
little bit larger
with the projection algorithms just a
fairly straightforward implementation
so here you're not a lot faster but you
can get larger so why is that
and you know the answer is we're not
doing anything fancy here we're doing
matrix vector multiplication solving a
sub problem so not doing qr
on a large problem of size twenty
thousand by forty
two thousand by forty thousand or
whatever we're just doing a vanilla
type random projection matrix vector
multiply go to a smaller prob sub
problem
memory access and so on to jim's point
that meshes much better with uh
these sorts of memory access issues it
can get quite a bit larger
so let me tell you about implementing
these ideas in large scale settings
and time is tight that i'm not going to
spend 10 minutes on i'll just spend one
or two
the short answer is do the same idea
but don't worry about flops worry about
communication
all right so do your random sampling a
random projection algorithm don't do
hadamard or something like that do
gaussians
all right gaussians are trivial to
parallel eyes you can do it in shared
memory or not shared memory environment
multiple cores are not your data center
um
get a sketch gaussians actually have the
advantage over the plus minus ones rod
and marker if you like
the fancy names but plus minus one
variables and
they they have better symmetry
properties and so you're going to get
better results on the condition number
all right so do an uh do a projection
like that
and then either solve the sub problem or
call and enter the algorithm
um so large can mean different things
that if people shared memory memory
passing mapreduce distributed computing
i'll give you the one minute summary of
lsrn which is the think of that as the
parallel version of blend and pick
and um and then the one minute summary
of how to extend the ideas to
l1
the idea is
generate a gaussian matrix
let um compute your r inverse like we
talked about before
and call summative algorithm whatever
algorithm
you can call um a conjugate gradient
based method
requires lots of dot products but it's
not so bad and ran pretty good actually
or you can dust off your textbooks which
i had actually seen this but i've
forgotten about this
and use something called the chebychev
semi-iterative method different
iterative method if you know about
methods
you know there's dozens that are based
on this and this is sort of an outlier
this actually does pretty well if you
have a guarantee on the condition number
which you very very rarely do and so
since all the scientific computing code
numeric linear algebra code
the driver on that is scientific
computing when you don't have bounds on
condition numbers
a lot less work done here than there
this requires lots of dot products that
doesn't this will always chug and give
you an answer this will fail terribly if
your
bound uncondition number is not correct
do a gaussian projection
guaranteed you have good results on the
condition number
if you have good results on condition
number call this
don't need all these dot products so
what you need is
here's the relevant snippet code lsqr
if you're going to do the matrix vector
multiplication per iteration you're
going to get two matrix vector
multiplications right so we do the
random projection
get the conditioning bases and we're
iterating now how much communication is
there
there's going to be two cluster-wide
synchronizations if we're going to do
lsqr which is the
the sort of state-of-the-art conjugate
gradient-based method for least squares
if you're going to do chair but chev's
semi-iterative i guess my color coding
is messed up here which even i'll reduce
all reduce two cluster-wide
synchronizations
here you're just gonna have all one one
cluster-wide synchronization
so instantiate the same idea we've been
talking about with sampling and
projections
but worry about communication don't
worry about flops
um if you want the
two-word summary of how all these ideas
for least squares regression
generalizes to things like l1 or
quantile regression
the two words are it does the the three
word summary after hundreds of pages of
math and so on by us and a lot of other
people is
it does messily so it's much much
messier
um l1 is not as nice a place as l2
you don't have unitarian variants the
condition number properties are worse
you don't call conjugate gradient
if you want to do iterations you need to
call something else what do you call
we actually had to use a randomized
interior point cutting plane method to
get the l1 regression to work on on the
terabyte of data not
not simplex not interior point not
nothing like that
an algorithm that was much more
expensive per iteration but required
many few iterations so much better on
communication properties
you put it in mapreduce we could do a
factor of a hundred more computation
with one point one more time so ten
percent not a factor of ten you know
280 versus three hundred ten seconds we
could do a factor of 100 more
computation um
theory and practice of input sparsity
regression algorithms matrix
multiplication results some of those
generalized if you have input sparsity
or something like student genre mang had
and you can use that to get good results
on
on the embedding for for low rank
problems and a range of other things
if you're of an algorithms background
you know about the clarkson woodruff
result they had a 10 page 15 page
analysis
they split the sub the space up into
heavy hitters and light hitters lots use
lots of ideas for data from data
streaming and so on
strongly came to me and said how is this
result even possible i said i don't know
it's a good result it'll actually be an
important result
um but and he said you know i can't
understand this stuff is there a simpler
way i said i don't know you might be we
might be able to do something more
directly
he came back one page check a couple
moments
done we have the results much much
cleaner and it boils down to that matrix
multiplication result
and there's trade-offs there between
running time and condition number
quality
if you optimize running time you're
typically going to be a trade-off and
you're going to be worse on condition
numbers
that's fine if you're on a low precision
but if you're going to feed this to
another algorithm
typically you don't want to do that you
don't want the best results on condition
numbers because if you optimize to that
you're going to do worse
so you want to be sub-optimal by both
methods which is one of the tricky
things right if you want to be best by
this measure or that
the results that actually work you know
aren't they're
they're slightly sub-optimal by each of
those measures so conclusions to part
two
least squares regression faster sampling
and theory and practice
statistical perspective you can get
better practical results without
sacrificing worst case quality by by
considering
biases and variances
the results here interesting took a lot
of work and i think it opens up the door
for a lot of other interesting questions
more generally than just the l2 case
since cl2 is so structured from a
statistical perspective so
um revisiting the nicer methods the
devils and the details lots of sort of
systems type issues we need to worry
about the data and various things i
glossed over those
implementing these ideas in parallel and
distributed a lot of the same meta
algorithms work
but don't over optimize to the
traditional metrics lots of future
directions
and i think it's coffee break time so to
wrap up
lots of very large modern massive data
sets are well modeled by matrices
existing algorithms both on the theory
side and on the implementation side
were developed for other reasons
scientific computing small scale data
analysis whatever
randomization is a powerful tool for
lots of things
in algorithms discrete algorithms also
in matrix
in matrix computations and i think it's
a great sort of model of proof aside
from being
interesting in its own right in a lot of
the questions we've raised in future
directions
nice model of proof of principle for
sort of bridging the gap between
algorithmic perspectives and statistical
perspectives in terms of
bridging the gap between the two to do
more principled much larger scale
analytics so that i think i'll wrap up
unless there are no burning questions
when we go to take a break catch michael
during the break
um if you are thinking of wandering away
because it's a beautiful day in berkeley
it's always a beautiful day
and if there's one topic that's even
more important for our field than
our general topic than matrices might be
optimization so
we're going to start optimization a key
topic after the break don't go away come
back in 30 minutes
so i'm sorry one reminder mike announced
that please don't bring food or drinks
into the hall i'm saying that free and
public before the next session
rather than the beginning of the next
slide
i'm glad